people would be shocked to know yes this
story from your new book which you have
not revealed yet right you met a Howard
Stern make loops is you met a
heterosexual couple in Boston yes on my
book tour for the last book he said this
my cell phone number seriously we want a
party with you and I said oh okay
interesting I get home I'm a little
sauce top and it's around 1:30 in the
morning you're in a hotel yes'm and I
text uh the guy and I'm about to go to
bed and I said to him I want you to be
very direct with me and tell me exactly
why you gave me your number good for you
I believe in the morning I wake up to a
fantastic series of tax they have
explored recently with other women
they've never been with a guy he's never
been with a guy in his life oh this is
right up your alley
this is like yoga and that fantasy
central as being a good gut boyfriend he
has said to her you know is that
something that's on your mind and she
has said to him listen there are only
two guys in the world I would ever be
with Paul Walker is dead and Andy Cohen
who is gay we would be willing to meet
you smoke it up and see where this goes
okay our our God one of the things that
was on my turning 40 bucket list was
look I'm a gold star how cool would it
be to lose my virginity if in my mind I
was like if I ever did it I would want
to do it with a straight couple
you might [ __ ] a woman that is that
would be the goal he set me an
incredible dick pic whoa that really
engaged me I start texting everyone I
know I text Kelly Ripa the dip and I go
just FYI do you see this couple your boy
is losing his virginity to Knights I
said to them find a cozy spot in the
hotel lobby bar
and I will meet you there after my
signing they almost faint when I walk in
the door and we wound up having a really
great 90 minute hangout when you're
having this conversation with them is
there any physical flirtation are you
great and I are playing footsie a little
bit off notions was engaging me
intensely right as it went on it became
clear to me that I wasn't going that
night to lose my virginity I don't think
she for her first time with two guys one
of them being me was ready for that
intense of an experience saying she just
wanted to watch her boyfriend [ __ ]
around with another guy could be and
what do you care
you're like lob it yeah let's fantastic
so what happens you go upstate went
upstairs and what is she wearing by the
way just help me I was wearing tight
jeans yeah boots compared to a celebrity
if you looks a little Rebecca Romijn II
know gay and hot she's Jewish
a Jewish wine yeah yeah Wow we wound up
naked what happened what happens is
there's a little bit of everything you
touch hard Did you touch her badge on a
little bit was it like new no it was
nice it was okay it was nice she had
great boobs is he jerking you off while
you're touching he's slowly uh touching
yeah yeah so the involvement with the
girl I mean that's what she could just
[ __ ] jump out the window but she you
playing around with her he's probably
making out with her a little bit they
really then went at it and it was like
did you watch them [ __ ] yes and it was
awesome do you liked it loved it why
what did you want that to lie watch them
gorgeous and what do you do while
they're [ __ ] you jerk masturbate I
get in and differ I look for openings
that I can you know get in he and I kind
of then wound up uh you know finishing
up doing what just jerking off that's it
yeah which enables virgin de yes ah yeah
I know but I'm starting a major book
tour come to my event in Boston Friday
night if you're a couple right and you
know is then
start writing the sequel this story is
in the new book I'm telling you much
more that is in my book right because
it's you and he's a huge fan of yours by
the way Stephen King is right now
killing himself because doctors never
turned out like his book toward never
Eric ended up in bed with him it was
such a good story and opportunity and
moment and once-in-a-lifetime this is
not something that ever happens